cameron you're here will you go through
some stories with us today
all right let's hit it first up
some breaking news from the
international house of pancakes yeah we
bring you the stories you want to know
usa today reports ihop has some new menu
items for your next bestie brunch
bubbles wine and brews that's right
alcohol is on the menu at ihop
officially making them the international
house of poop pam
oh my god i hop you know how i love
brunch brunch is a way of life for me
but i'm just worried at ihop when you're
drinking it's going to be go from ihop
to eye wasted to i drunk tested my ex
too i hate myself in the morning
that's a really slippery slope
it sounds like profit for uh ihop
ding ding ding
well you know i have an uh suggestion
for ihop as you boost your sales nothing
goes with a big old stack of buttermilk
pancakes like a crisp
refreshing glass of wine
that's clean organic and from winemaker
cameron diaz oh
she is selling the product i know she's
my she's like my support here
you know i'd like you to quickly tell
everyone else what you told me because
you made me realize that i didn't know
about wine sure so my partner my
co-founder uh catherine power and i we
love to drink wine and we were drinking
wine one day and
realized that you know everything else
in our life
we're leveling up on we everything we
drink eat is organic and we just
realized we never
questioned what was in wine and sort of
naively thinking that it was just
fermented grapes and then we sort of
took this deep dive into wine making
and we real found out that there's over
73 ingredients that can be added to wine
without any ex disclosure
and so we kind of just made clean
delicious wine so we don't add any extra
sugar we don't add any colors or
concentrates
um it's all organic and we made first
and foremost delicious wine am i correct
uh
the only thing i am upset about this
line with is that i don't have enough so
let me just hear it oh yeah okay here we
go cheers
it's actually glass you guys
okay
whoa that was a big gulp
so good
ihop it's called aveline
[Laughter]
wow
um cameron it's your story okay thank
you
my turn okay so there's a new trend in
dating we have to talk about in style
reports it's called
hard balling ouch
i mean
whoa
and it's this is the definition of it
okay so don't get so crazy okay and it's
when you treat your uh dating life like
you're running a fortune 500 company and
you're um you're the ceo of that company
and you make hard decisions and you make
them fast so anyone who doesn't meet
your criteria has got to go ross yeah i
think you should treat it like a
business if you're not what i'm looking
for get out next move on but i also
think there's a time in people's lives
where you should play a little softball
if you know what i mean like just just
have some fun i have a girlfriend who
kept saying i keep these guys keep
leaving me they keep leaving me i go
what are the first dates like she says
well i asked them if they want kids i
asked them i'm like girl what are you
doing on date one you don't ask if you
want kids you ask if you like pizza or
the color blue but so she was a natural
hardballer from the beginning because
she's like this is what i want are you
in no so she shouldn't be looking at it
that she they're leaving her she should
be going you know what you don't add up
to me you don't you're you're not my
you're not at my place but that's okay
because okay
then you least know you know i mean at
least you know like i'm we're not in the
same place and i think that's what
dating is all about i hear you i care i
think it's just important to know what
you want um and when you see it hold on
to it and if you find something that's
not for you don't be afraid to move on
don't be afraid to leap onto the unknown
because you'll find what you need
eventually and mostly if if the other
person is not holding on to you
let go of them
okay ding ding that part yes please been
there
that be that might be my favorite piece
of advice that came out of this all
right um next cameron um i have a tick
tock video that i want to show you um
take a look if you don't have earbuds
okay it's hard it's hard to talk on the
phone it just keeps on falling out
so uh go old school
analog
let's get involved you got to plug it in
it's not wireless
um
uh can you name that person
uh tom cruise okay so you see tom cruise
yes okay
that is not tom cruise
it's actually this new thing it's called
a deep fake
cnn business reports that there are
dozens of these deep fake tom cruise
videos and they've got millions and
millions of views on tick tock but they
were actually made by a visual effect
artist in this case chris ume
using artificial intelligence cgi and a
real actor what
what that's terrifying i know and the
reason that i wanted to bring this up is
because there's a lot of misinterpreters
out there a lot of misinformation and
you may think someone is saying
something out there or being someone or
doing something but it's actually not
that person
so
chris says that with his work with
celebs like tom it's just for fun and he
just wanted to do videos that he had you
know we're having fun with and he'd take
them down and he's removing them but
let's just be aware of deep fakes let's
know they exist so we can empower
ourselves that if we see something
that's questionable we question it and
um
you know if you ever see a video of me
ripping down the highway flipping people
the bird out of my window and my minivan
that's not a deep fake
um i drive a minivan and i have road
rage so live with it
most importantly i just want to say if
anybody ever does this for me just put
me on a face with a better jawline okay
oh hey and before we go
parents love embarrassing their kids
just for sport do you ever do that no no
i would never do that to my child okay
well just wait till they go to college
okay because the golf medal for this
goes to david and whitney scott from
arkansas when their daughter moved to
college this fall fox news reports that
they gave her a giant blanket with their
faces on it right just to embarrass them
at school this i mean save your money
nobody wants this gift i'd rather have a
gift with tom cruise's face on it okay
you and me both
[Music]
you